what was left of CNN's credibility is
now completely in the toilet the
self-proclaimed
facts first network under fire for
another botched Trump Russia report this
time they claim the president was the
reason why a CIA spy was extracted from
Russia the story has been debunked by
numerous outlets and it turns out Trump
had nothing to do with it and wasn't
even in office when the decision was
made despite all that CNN still reported
it this morning and new numbers show the
network's spent 181 minutes hyping the
so-called bombshell earlier this week
sadly it's not just CNN that's clinging
to the bogus story check out what NBC
asked former Secretary of State
Condoleezza Kitt's possible that the
Russia's election interference actually
worked it actually elected Donald try I
don't I think there is any evidence of
that and you know I really don't think
that that's a good conversation to have
I think that really does devalue the
people in Wisconsin and Michigan and
others who decided to vote for President
Trump but whether you like this
president or not whether you believe
that he should have been President or
not let's let's give the credit to the
Americans who went out and voted for
somebody who they thought would bring
change alright well I have a theory on
all of this I think you might agree with
me I'm looking forward to I think the
media might help get Donald Trump
reelected and here's why all they do is
report on Donald Trump fake news sharpie
gate and they give no room for any of
the Democrats running for president you
don't hear anything about any of the
other Democrats it's Trump 24/7 and I
think it's to the detriment of the
Democrats run it well I understand your
point because he takes up so much air in
the room and they give it to him well
boy do we give it to him but I must say
you know Donald Trump I think every
political conversation I have a lot of
them is tends to always come back to
Donald Trump he is still the you know
hundred pound gorilla or whatever
800-pound gorilla in their room I mean
he's the guy a hundred pound gorilla
whatever
but he's the biggest of the big so I
think obviously and also with the chaos
and like yesterday with John Bolton
leaving and all the arguments in the
previous weekend with the idea of
bringing the Taliban to Camp David
imagine today 9/11 just would have been
awful
I think people people the media has to
cover the president he's the president
United States but your point is
well-taken I do agree with you apologize
or not and not only CNN I love that NBC
clip and I love condi rice with the
pushback I mean not only she she she
almost was too nice she said that's not
a conversation we should have how about
stop saying that
stop saying that Russia got Trump
elected and they're still doing it so
they're still gonna play that the Russia
game regardless this story that has been
debunked and CNN is just kind of kind of
let it fade away but they're gonna keep
up the Russia thing and they're gonna
keep up the did did the Russians get
Trump elected so no no one's learned at
181 minutes Katie I mean they probably
boosted their ratings quite a bit when
they're back to the Russia well I don't
think it's boosted the ratings but from
the zero to one nice thing for you to
say about them yeah the interesting
thing to me is that CNN and Savannah
Guthrie claimed to be concerned about
Russia interference in the elections but
anytime she says and gives Russia credit
for maybe tilting the election towards
President Trump she's actually embolden
ashan propaganda and giving Russia a win
and every single time that someone at
CNN reports a story incorrectly and puts
a source a CIA source at risk
the Russians do things in America and
they've done it and you know that's a
huge problem you're going you're setting
up the situation where Americans are now
debating about the Russia issue and
tearing each other apart politically
which the one thing in the mullah report
that we know is true that was one of the
Russians Russians goal when they did the
Facebook guides and kind of the Twitter
Farms was to sow dissent in America so
every time the media acts like they're
concerned about classified information
they're worried about protecting sources
they've actually exposed the source and
they've actually emboldened the Russian
propaganda by continuing to give Russia
credit for something that didn't
actually do and that goes to one of the
theories data that's floating around
right now the person who is an asset in
the Kremlin people think that he was the
one that gave all the disinformation
about Donald Trump - Christopher Steele
which he cooked the dossier up with him
that's why he was had to have been
brought out of that country as it broke
and so maybe that is why then CNN is
clinging to their story well I think
they're trying to get ahead of it now
because the durum investigation is in
flames that was yeah that will be an
interesting ones on pins and needles
waiting for that one to come out I think
when Secretary Rice talks about this
it's worth listening Mike she
understands Russians very well and it's
giving Russians way too much credit
right and it's building them up to a
point of ridiculousness the thing that
she didn't say and she's very polite
shouldn't say it which is that if that
were true
where was the Obama administration
because they have responsibility for
election security in the United States
and I don't know if that will be a part
of the durum investigation but I feel
like they kind of get off easy because
no one really talked about we talked
about the media no one else talks about
that the other thing I would point out
is back in the olden days and they're
like 10 years ago there was really no
way to fight back when a reporter
wouldn't back down even if you knew the
story wasn't true if they wouldn't
retract it you would you know you could
complain a little bit you could try to
get it out there to people but there was
no Twitter there was no Facebook there
was no direct way to communicate
directly to people to say that story is
wrong so I do think that it has helped
that social media has been a good
leveling of the playing field so you
like what the president tweets fake news
no I don't let me just rebut some of
this that I've heard here because I
don't agree with it though everyone what
is I think CNN I don't think that
they've acted recklessly they are
standing by the story because they
believed and they said partly
responsible that that the anxiety over
the fact that the president was having
meetings in the Oval
office with the Russians you know later
this is the president who stood by
Vladimir Putin say well I believe him
not American even though the Washington
Post said that wasn't the case
no what they said by the way both the
New York Times and CNN went to the
administration before they ran their
story and asked the see we run is
because there was no danger the Russians
knew this guy knew where he was there so
as nobody's life was in dangerous just
not true but what I would say is that
you have a situation where CNN when they
were found to be wrong I think it was a
story about scaramouche II they fired
three people including a Pulitzer Prize
they should fire the whole news they
were wrong about Russia collusion no no
they were not clinging
are you kidding here clinging this is
what who colluded well I'm Sammy when
you were talking you said you're acting
like Russia didn't interfere and it like
Russia and Russian propaganda didn't
influence votes in this country talking
about collusion not in okay and Obama
didn't stand up and stand and we have a
pictures for Obama standing staring down
at Putin and saying stop it and did it
work I'm trying to get wow I guess
because I really listened while trying
to get Mitch McConnell to agree let's
put out a bipartisan right here last
word dinner I just said they all to
blame though that the Obama
administration and has been very
skillful in trying to cast all of the
blame against Trump and the Russians
when they've really were in charge of
election security what would you have
had do you think Hillary Clinton thinks
Obama should have done something more
yeah guaranteed and then what would
Trump and the Republicans have said your
interfere they're worried about politics
not national security